control oh I'm ready to roll and I've
been daydreaming
[Music]
feels like I've been walking on ice on
everything going alright in a drum down
our bodies I know we live in money time
we gonna have a good time
a dozen hands up to the sky we gonna get
toasted
I've been feeling it all day I wanna let
it go I wanna lose I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials but I'm living
button second ahem the floor I'm closed
on Sunday you're closed on Sunday you
guys how do we do an episode after
today's episode I don't know but it's
gonna be easier than doing an episode
it's gonna be easier than yesterday's
episode because doing an episode after a
perm useable performance impossible
we're just still living on that musical
ha you know er please don't sing it
because I could not get that dope in my
sleep my sleep and the thing is it
wasn't even like on the tip of my tongue
it was so engrained in my brain it was
honestly torture and I woke up and it
wasn't in my head I was listening to new
music Friday and then I started watching
the premium videos we put out yesterday
I was like oh my god I can't do this to
myself again I was so sterically
laughing from the videos on our
Instagram oh my god they were so [ __ ]
fun they were made by toasters thank you
guys anytime a toaster make something
farting it's so funny in these two
videos of my vocals overlaid with these
random videos where hysterical the album
did not come out last night which like
made me a little nervous I'm like okay
was this afraid um definitely not a
prank because like that song exists he
released the tracklist yeah and he
actually just released a statement that
says to my fans thank you for being
loyal and patient we were specifically
fixing mixes on everything we need
follow god and water we're not going to
sleep until this album is out but I mean
it's bittersweet because I was excited
for I actually stayed up till midnight I
pulled a snitch because I wanted to hear
the album and it didn't come out but it
made me realize that if anyone wants
listened to in cottony music they have
to listen to our version right no this
is the most amazing publicity maybe
Kanye needed more time because he was so
impressed with my my version that he
wants like mixing some of my vote yes
it's like when you every star talks
about like the bake and makeup companies
like talking and so they don't put
things out at the same time like the big
the big fingers so I do think it'll come
out today so he won't have been like
late even though you just expect things
to come at midnight if it's coming out
on Friday but he's at the oculus right
now they closed down like the whole
oculus start setting up a stage or
something the choir for Sunday service
is there they're filming something
it's all very and he was on Kimmel last
night saying tomorrow night okay tonight
he has a special performance so things
are happening things are I'm I'm not
gonna hold my
breath that it comes out today but like
we will have it eventually and it's
gonna be the perfect version of it so I
can wait and we got really some good new
music today yeah we did a sweet we
really did Lady Antebellum I guess
they're coming out with an album and
they're just dropping singles every
single Church every eye are left right
and center is oh and Ariana Grande is so
good I saw the twist except people
weren't feeling it I'm like what's not
to like no no I I understood their gripe
there was not enough ariana yes I agree
it just sounds like the same song with
Ariana in the background and just three
new lines that's not us usually happens
when someone's a feature on a track
because it's Ariana and she's like a
main artist we expected more but I I
loved they're calling it a remix I
wouldn't call it a remix because it
sounds exactly the same
no but just a little bit more breathy
it's a remix when someone like they add
a verse to it and she added a verse all
right
I think it's great I don't know why like
what's not good it's a letdown like you
know Leo and powerhouses that have
already onna it's fine you just thought
it was gonna be more mm-hmm and like
when Lisa was teasing it on her live I
guess she literally put in the best part
because I'm like oh this some [ __ ]
stuff
and it's like no that's the peak of it
you know yeah that's like the only time
yeah I understand yeah we always want
more
not enough Grande but yes she came out
with like a really good song Selena
Gomez also came out with the second song
that we didn't really discussed but we
watched it yesterday in the car and we
came to the grand conclusion that it was
certainly not it yeah I was certainly
uncertain and the music video was cute
like she was a good dancer she's looking
fire so I'm here for looking really
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
and the song just was not it you should
have like bask in the glory of a she
should be like everyone is still
obsessed I needed to lose everyone
everyone is living for it he news can't
contain their tears yeah so they're
Hackney is like so clear this week right
right their skin has never been clear
they should really she should have let
that last like another week
yeah oh I agree also Rikki padilha made
an excellent point about Kanye's album
that it's probably he's remastering it
to add snitches snaps oh yeah oh yeah
they are quite um unique yeah and I
think that's just what the song probably
win can we talk about a snitch made the
news yesterday yes
okay you know what I genuinely don't
understand though my grand conclusion
you guys like we're famous
like people thought like the way that
like journalists write about us like so
disrespectfully like we're famous ya
know it's I always joked like I think we
all know like that was so weird I didn't
see honestly like enjoyable I was living
40 just like recapture episode
they couldn't even muster up some vile
words to say so they suggested that you
watch it yourself and you think about it
wait you guys didn't see vulture which
is a New York magazine like subgroup
they brought an article that Kanye West
like gave me a song and like they were
like we're confused and like there was
like super condescending and like filled
with like complete factual errors I mean
it's like you release it this is always
with me they had to release an optin
editor's note saying they corrected
something with like some shady [ __ ] in
it and then that update have an error in
it again and then eventually they
corrected I have screenshots of both but
they never mentioned that they had a no
they took out the word school they took
out the word school they replace it with
movie and they never liked you but when
you update an article you have to did so
like they just absolutely yeah
Oh Madame Chuck it was the most poorly
written article but like living for me
being in New York magazine and living
for my name being in the title with
Kanye West so I have officially come to
the conclusion after this morning like
if I'm in an article with Kanye West
again the headline like I'm famous right
okay so ever wrote the articles like
obviously really invested toaster cuz
they know that but also like not you
know yeah no it wasn't that was like
like this thing I ever saw wouldn't go
for it you know it was like really shady
and rude for absolutely no reason but
like still don't care
grateful to be consider famous right and
grateful that someone is watching our
show paying attention and giving it like
the press that it deserves yeah you know
he always just like do our show oh my
god it's like not until like Cuba
Gooding jr. has 14 allegations against
him do they listen to what we have said
yep but now they're listening to what we
have sound well we have snapped so just
yesterday it was a crazy day big day for
the chest feel like we might have some
new toasters watching welcome how are
you this is the Millennium morning show
we'd alive Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube we talk
about the Kardashians Bravo Kanye West
anything you really want all the news
you really care about we have a snitch
we have a snitch cam we're also all
sisters
while yeah we like birth they say mom's
same dad we're also available as a
podcast Spotify iTunes stitcher podcast
apps all over the world cashbox I Heart
Radio Public Radio we also they don't
stop podcasting like we probably do
about 40 hours of podcasting a monthly
and patreon for premium content www
patreon.com slash morning shows we're
also recording another podcast episode
today to be ran on Monday with a very
special guest - mm we're not gonna
announce it because like I'm just too
afraid of it falling through it's the
level of guests that would that we don't
do just strictly podcast episodes like
at noon with just anyone like yeah
they're can you come to the studio at
10:30 where I'm sorry it didn't work out
but it's a level of guests that like we
come to you although it's not Kanye so
like I just want to put that out there
cuz it makes it seem like it is but it's
like it's someone who's like super
famous super thing is and an icon of
this show yes especially especially for
for 1kg I mean you're Chuck this is like
the this is dreams coming true I believe
the toasters might actually guess it
maybe let's yeah and after the episodes
recorded you'll know who it is yeah so
that's great oh and we have merch it's
like you're a new viewer and you're like
oh yeah
I need a sweatshirt shop morning toast
calm we have what we have sweatshirts we
have all of our sorry actually things
are now selling out but we have the to
the iconic teal sweatshirt is still
available we have it in pink as well we
have the cropped hoodies I came home the
other day from like we have we just been
having like really long days this week
yes you know what I've been like loving
it
I've been like eight but then I get home
and I'm like oh my god I'm so exhausted
I've been wearing heels traversing the
city all day and I'm also a little cold
now because it's like well yeah I'm
wearing my windbreaker and I put on that
cropped hoodie I guess I never tried it
on before haven't it was so delicious
and so comfortable it is literally one
of my favorite things to wear like it's
made out of butter no and it's like
thick it really keeps you warm like just
like a jacket no it was like it was so
nice to the touch that I couldn't wear a
bra because I was I want every skin I
want my whole epidermis to feel this
yeah so shot morning toast calm I don't
know it better
um and so here's what we do here we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of the morning toast and
Jackie does that from her pink iPad and
I do other things too you know okay like
telling everyone that today's episode is
brought to you by mod Z Wow okay
mod Z is a new sponsor of ours I have
been working with them on a personal
level because like that's what they do
over at mod Z and basically it is a
website it's a revolutionary online
interior home design service that starts
around $50 it is a fraction of a
fraction of the fraction of a cost of
hiring an actual interior designer and
so much easier just take a few photos
and measurements of your space for an
eternal take their style quiz and the
mod Z designers create to custom design
plans for you so you did that yes I did
that I uploaded photos I have a spare
bedroom in my apartment that we're
turning into an office and the struggle
has been real and you upload photos of
the space you do like a whole quiz
letting like you pick pictures of things
that you like because I don't know how
to describe my tastes right what I like
and I don't maybe she will and they
understand that people don't want to
describe traditional minimum order so I
just like click pictures of things that
I like and I send them all the
measurements and they are going to
design the room for me with their mods
II interior designers and it's like I
don't I can't have it an interior
designer remains and this is
their groundbreaking 3d technology lets
you see different layouts and tour your
virtual space with their price matching
guarantee and exclusive savings you can
shop all the beautiful furniture in your
mod Z designs at once from one easy
checkout oh that's everything you can
get unlimited revisions plus mod Z
guarantees you land on this design you
love or hey you get your money back this
month only when our listeners go to mod
Z comm start a design project and use
the code toast
you'll get 20% off that 20% off for our
listeners at mod Z mo d sy comm and the
code is toast mo d sy dot-com use code
toast for 20% off I'm just gonna do
something to your microphone no no no
wait go back to how you weren't thinking
that our experience you just very
tenderly touched my breasts because
people were hearing the windbreaker and
like they're breaking wind the wind was
breaking I understand how you know
stressful that could be for some people
but it's just
- cool windbreaker I mean it is and I
will never stop wearing it for how much
I paid for it I will have to be buried
in this and I'm also gonna wear it to my
daughter's prom mitzvah and my son's Bar
Mitzvah and I don't know made me mean
that's like 50th anniversary wedding
extravaganza I'm gonna wear it on my
honeymoon I'm gonna wear it to the beach
like I have to wear this jacket 10,000
times in order to make it worth the
price well it's looking great on you
it's already worth the the price yeah Oh
so I'm like filming a video today at
Hearst so like it's gonna be very cute
right her Steve I Steve Ives cool well
let's get into the stories we have
something good I love them we have a
game just like dumb celebrity news live
for it this story is not dumb celebrity
news but it's celeb news because Kanye
did an interview I guess this is the
Kanye because he's not doing as much
press as he'll ever do because he hasn't
album coming out and he did an interview
with Zane Lowe on Apple musics beats one
where he's just talking about he's
talking about at all he we talked about
abuse one for a minute because also
today Taylor Swift did an interview with
Zane and it comes out today and it's
like where are all these interviews like
beats of music but we're like like how
do you ever listen to it actually last
night when we were looking for the album
Zach put on this interview I've never
knew you person interviews on Apple
music but it's beats beats one beats one
official it's like the network it's like
the radio station within I mean it's not
radio but it's like the station within
Apple music it's just all very confusing
and I see these clips like all over
Twitter but I've never actually seen
like where you can go and find the
interview and who's name written who was
Zach sang that's saying I can talk to
you about this he is just a regular old
oh boy he knows Liz and Ariana I think
they like all grew up in like wherever
they know each other from so does he
know Kristen maybe that's a good
question we should ask her and he
basically like started like a podcast
like show of like interviewing people
and he has friends in high places and
basically like would interview like
Ariana whatever and now like his show
was just like a one-stop shop where like
every single celebrity ever just like
those on there he asked like really good
questions and he's just like really
funny and like it's just like a really
great like experience to watch it's
[ __ ] hilarious that was like the
morning toast honestly because they film
it and it's a podcast he asked great
questions and
he has like friends in higher places but
I actually watched the episode with Liz
Gillies in Madison brows so I watched
you two I was dating it was so funny but
because of Liz and Madison I think like
they talked the whole time so I don't
know how Zach saying is but like he got
them in the door and it was funny
because he does not watch time to see
that all clearly and so he didn't ask
like the questions that needed to be
asked but I'm talking about like her
playing um Nicollette Sheridan was
[ __ ] hilarious Clippers yeah about
going to college and that's that the
info I needed thank you yeah okay so so
the story so he's spilling all in this
interview he is a quote porn addict and
he been premarital sex from the Jesus is
Katun team what he's also talked I mean
until I haven't listened to a little
interview yet I don't like want to speak
on clips out of context but he also
talked about um the episode where he was
handcuffed and like sent to a hospital
basically saved his life and that's when
he became like very very spiritual he
read hid awakening the most space that I
had to think is when I went to the
hospital one of the things that happened
when I went to the hospitals I started
reading the Bible and I started writing
and copying out Bible verses he now sees
himself as a son of God now that I'm in
service to Christ my job is to spread
the gospel to let people know what Jesus
has done for me I've spread a lot of
things however he may have taken the
word of Ward too seriously while working
on Jesus's King that's page six is
editorializing I think I don't know
about that there's times where I was
asking people to not have premarital sex
while they were working on the album he
also claimed to be a pornography addict
in the interview quote playboy was my
gateway gateway into full-on pornography
addiction my dad had a Playboy left out
at age five and it affected almost every
choice I made for the rest of my life
from age five to now having to kick the
habit so interesting crazy I mean the
whole premarital sex and like asking
people you're working with not to have
sex it's like a little extreme but kind
of shame artist and now that I am one of
his minions I obey everything he says so
I like him and everything is that yeah
and I want to listen and everyone if
you're interested that you listen to the
full interview because it it always
makes more sense coming from Kanye's
mouth and it does when you like read it
you're like how do you say what and then
you listen to the interview and it's
like oh okay like he's just like stating
his opinion I don't know yeah no they
definitely blow things up and I sure if
I watch this interview like I wouldn't
think whatever
was so crazy I mean like as we've
learned you know first hand it's
everything that comes out of paychecks
it's pretty much a lie so I would rather
watch you interviewed then than speak on
it no but I feel like also even wouldn't
just transcribe someone like when you
transcribe what is on this show like we
sound moronic some yeah when you listen
to it it's like oh there's just the
conversational conversational it's a
stream of conscious and like I'm just
listening to someone's looking and I
feel the same way specifically about
Kanye but a lot about a lot of artists
so I hate to read like recaps of
interviews even that Taylor Swift is in
vogue like I want to read her interview
not someone's summary of it and not
someone's decision to clip one thing and
and cut out the other and just like
without context right so context is key
gal so listen to the interview and
listen to the morning shows yeah I just
feel like we've got to get Connie on the
shows we've got to I don't think it's
gonna happen like any time so many there
but I think like if we keep doing this
like for the rest of our lives like
what's keep growing like month to month
growth yeah so maybe in the next few
years like we will be Zack saying exact
possible you totally be Zack saying yeah
totally snitch saying has a nice ring to
it totally is saying a Jewish thank you
okay next story is a snitch it's a Smith
special and also I'm having about it too
because let me echo post supports
boyfriend Christian McCaffrey with her
manicure okay and this is also just like
major confirmation that they are very
much together they are more serious than
ever and like for a second I thought
they might have broken up but they are
going strong you know she's like very
private but then also not private yeah
like she wants us to know when she wants
us to know right nothing further
nothing more you know literally I think
last week we were talking and I thought
they had broken up me didn't put in
anything and then cut to the next day
he's making eggs Apple doughnuts in her
house like her mom's recipe yeah that's
amazing yeah so I think I needed to and
he commented on her Instagram yesterday
what if he said like Oh
videographer like deserves a raise or
some [ __ ] like that you know that's such
a new boyfriend think yeah how do you
Elton that's like obviously in the
comment of someone who doesn't use
social media a lot you know yeah like
you don't get paid which is what makes
no sense yeah I don't get paid to take
someone pictures exactly
this is really key also is there any
comment on social media that's more
annoying than the person who took your
picture be like photo God question my
good leg yeah like you're an [ __ ] I
don't ever feel the need to give someone
photo credit look if either of you
[ __ ] take my picture like it's not
going in my caption okay no it's so
crazy and it's like what are you trying
to achieve with that comment like to let
people know that you were there like
it's so obnoxious
you were there that should be enough for
you hey hey no you know ya know Chris
McCaffrey just wanted everyone to know
that he was there unless it's kendall
Jenner taking your photo right no unless
it's Annie Leibovitz
okay unless unless it's Ansel Adams okay
himself taking your photo like no one
needs to know who took it
unless it's Mario Testino unless it's
like pertinent to the story of the
situation you know unless it's Cole
Sprouse right
that's what I'm saying right unless it's
Jill Bensimon no unless it's Kelly
Bensimon yes so could you be happy like
Hillary or unless it's a paparazzi and
then legally you do have to say
photographers oh yeah unless it's like
Getty Images right and like you don't
wanna get sued like Gigi Hadid did first
term and JLo just got sued too soon
there soon laugh tonight left or right
anyways love this a couple
I was just paparazzi that so I could get
sued you know it's a lawsuit I'd be glad
to take on no but you really wouldn't
know I have no money please don't sue me
yeah okay spent all my money on this
jacket are you ready for our next story
because a lot of news is coming out of
Drake's birthday party and the first one
is a doe and her oh and her snatch
snatch in this and how she is the
snatchler oh my god she literally
disappeared came back snatch alert adele
continues to flaunt her epic weight loss
is she cozies up to birthday boy drake
after gushing over her quote kind and
funny pal in a sweet snap so these
photos of adele going need ranks
birthday she's wearing like such an
Adele dress like black velvet off the
shoulder high seventies pony that's just
iconic I love her it's like tiny leaks
to the gods the tiniest time I've ever
seen them arm pops out in one picture
and it's like whose tiny arm is that a
to Jos
but it's also crazy because like her she
looks the same sometimes people do so
much weight and it's like oh they look
like who is that person
yeah but it's like she still has that
Adele spirit and vibe but like she's the
snatcher and I'm so happy for her
because she looks incredible she looks
incredible and she is like she's
beautiful like no matter what she looks
like but I feel like this is definitely
like she's was in a bad place because
she's getting a divorce I'm like now
she's out of that like dark place and
like you just lighten up when you do and
like you could see that lightness like
in her body and her face like in her
smile like I'm just like living for like
this an Adele snatched it out it's not
so good soon Adele send it out or like a
- no and this is just like a wonderful
moment for you know fans all over the
world yeah and it just gets you excited
for like new Adele music and just like a
new Adele by then I loved her old web so
it's like I'm just excited period yeah
we're getting new music and she's like
go any drinks birthday party in like she
is like the queen of fun you know every
now and then she will like step into
Hollywood like I think she lives in
London like a very quiet simple life and
she could go to any party any event that
she wants to but she does it but every
now and then she will step out like she
went out to dinner I remember that crew
Emma Stone Jennifer Lawrence Adele like
running around town being so fabulous
going to drag queen nights at different
gay bars yes like tooling all around
chilling all around town also Adele okay
so when this Adele story came out I
realize I don't follow Adele on
Instagram so I went back to catch up she
was out the Spice Girls concert she was
with her friends she has a jewel in
every picture like and it's very subtle
so unless you're looking for it you
don't see it but I tell Jules and it's
like how does that affect her vocals
like when your vocals like when you're
one of the most talented vocalists of
our generation like we're putting our
entire like culture on your back like
you can be chillin
where can you I don't know maybe that's
what that says but she's also not on
tour right now maybe she goes on tour
and she doesn't jewel yeah she's just
writing but other stuff is coming out of
this Drake birthday party that's my next
story so um it looks so fun said it
wasn't invited I see Adele's looking sad
that's all the news agency sorry and so
unlike you usually it's like a Greeks
birthday is one story that they're two
big stories its do the Kylie one of
course okay so the first big story is
that Mandela stepping out she's the
snatcher and I'm like obsessed I'm
obsessed with the dress I'm obsessed
with the hair like but your hair today
is Adele 70s lab is it del likes no it's
one of the other seventies flan do you
think what would you consider a Dells
hair color to me like strawberry blonde
Yeah right
she's just straight blonde here great
that's gonna take but like I was like
think of her as a red redhead yeah I
think she probably like
changes her hair color back in the
dishes really reminding me of with this
conversation and then the jewel and the
Britishness so silver burner and it's
like what color is her hair red yeah
like you just associate her with red
hair because she that's ounces hair but
either way low in real life she's never
she's never had a yellow hair she has
but maybe it's just while she was she
was filming ya know like red carpet
stuff like for promotional G ot she's
never worn red hair no she probably does
triple yellow Slee identified to Sansa
also I think at certain point she was
wearing a wig yes I think she like in
the early seasons like she is a redhead
and she had red hair but now she's like
a yellow hair that's the same with
Daenerys like I'm just here showing up
with brown hair it's like what where's
your love for me - yellow haired that's
what it is Stannis Baratheon black of
hair
Joffrey breath in gold you know how that
scene is the best he's redeemed in the
back it's like readily the back of half
Stannis Baratheon black of hair
rubber Baratheon black of hair Joffrey
brother gold
[Laughter]
oh my god that's what we were doing in
LA when so yes you had black hair
assiduously talking about my hair black
hair okay next story new couple alert I
have no clue if there's veracity of
claims but I'm hoping that there is
because Drake and Kylie Jenner according
to Us Magazine appear into each other at
rappers birthday party who reported it
US magazine unfortunately even though US
magazine does respect the hell out of
the morning toast they're usually wrong
on stuff like this and I would assume
once again that they are wrong
because this makes no sense like Kylie
could never what do you mean there's so
much beef
oh remember okay so Kobe - yeah yeah I'm
not cool and people say that keke do you
love me is about Kim yeah round the
corner from your house like they fight
each other and Drake are like long-lost
lovers right and then he had like nude
pictures of Kim like there's so many
like theories about them and we're
smoke there isn't always a fire but
there's definitely something weird going
on between drinking the Kardashians and
I just don't think Kylie would be like
selling herself like that you know okay
so I'm just gonna say like I if that
part is true
I hope that this isn't true like Rihanna
was there too and then people were like
Rihanna was with Drake so it's like who
was he with you know yeah well I hope
that that stuff about the beef with like
Kim and Drake isn't true and that kind
of train could happily ever after
Oh sing but like that's an ideal world
and things just don't work out for us
like that but suppose she confirmed - at
the birthday party even um oh I don't
know I guess it feel like your
brother-in-law's meeting with him why
would you even be there right so it's
like either the story is completely true
or not true at all like either Kylie
wasn't even at the birthday party or if
she was they definitely were like
mingling because if she was was that
means there's no beef yeah so if she was
there there's something something going
on but if she wasn't there there
definitely is something going on because
she would never have even set foot in
that party if there was beef with the
family interesting but maybe like her
friends were going and like she didn't
realize whose birthday it was Kylie
smarter than that she knows exactly
where she's going she went into the
studio with Tyga
she was just dropping someone off she
didn't in there by the way that is I
could totally see how that time I think
was a misconception like she dropped one
of her friends off who was like wanting
to be thirsty with like a rapper who was
in the studio um and Tyga studios are
big they have more than one room in them
like she liked the fact that she ended
up dropping someone off at a studio
where Tiger was also that doesn't
surprise me
yeah like nuts an act that I didn't
believe in was his place for a private
event like she knows where she's going
it's not just like a restaurant nobody
acts like the most popping party in LA I
feel like she could be there even if
there's beef cuz it's like yeah but she
never leaves her house what if she is if
she does leave it's always because she
has a plan for a chance to celebrate
Sophia's you know collab or the party of
the years in town Drake's birthday
Adele's there I don't know I don't know
I think Kylie was like I'm a big Adele
fan oh that's probably that's bigger
than the beef in the dam or maybe the
beef is squashed like yeah it's still
weird and like we're not all gonna like
hook up with Drake but we could go to
his birthday party he sounds cool
yeah Breanna was there so yeah we know
she hates him yeah I'm sure she wouldn't
Rihanna like Andrea we're dating for
like five seconds like she couldn't get
away from him fast enough that was one
of the most iconic moments in pop
culture history when he presented her
with the award at the VMAs and like when
she killed her and she was like get the
[ __ ] out of my face Oh get the [ __ ] out
of my face
like I feel like that moment isn't
spoken enough culturally like the impact
it had on like the entire world me
specifically like it's hilarious it's
hilarious I agree
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story because it's a crazy one
right as well sure I love to do a crazy
story well I also want to talk about
Jeffrey star because that's what we've
been oh yeah consuming and we need to
talk about it but did the final story a
woman was diagnosed with breast cancer
after it was detected by a tourist
attractions thermal camera look at this
picture she went through the camera a
Scottish family vacation provided one UK
woman with a potentially life-saving
discovery when walking through the
thermal camera at camera obscura and
world of illusions with her family on a
trip to eat in Bergen a 41 year old Bao
Gail noticed an odd heat patch on her
left breast which led to a breast cancer
diagnosis in a feature on the world of
illusions website Gill explained that
she and her family visited Edinburgh
they have lived capital of Scotland with
her family during the school holidays in
May of this year the Berkshire residence
said that after visiting the Edinburg
Castle this was a Draco Dorinda medley
the Berkshire resident yes they were at
what is it called state of matter who
state matter who's John matter state of
grace anyways you have to see this
picture basically she goes through an
x-ray machine in there is like a thermal
yellow being some arrests and led to a
breast cancer diagnosis first of all
that so said that she has breast cancer
but how crazy like and to catch it much
earlier than she would have right and
also what kind of cameras like x-ray on
your body like I thought you were gonna
say in the airport machine remember when
they introduced it you know it's like a
standard in pretty much every single
airport those machine said like x-ray
your whole body and you have to stand
and put your hands up do you remember
when it was like a news they're like
those machines are Steven thank you yes
everyone's like I don't consent it's
like you're totally fine like it's
literally like not even real no I just
wonder if they can see if you have a
tampon in isn't interesting yeah but you
can see when you walk out there's a
screen with your skin and it tells them
where they need to Pat down mine is
always my back because where my bra
strap I wear like industrial size bras
with like 600 clips and you can see
first of all everyone is the same
silhouette it's like a man for everyone
but like what that's what you see like
on the outside but maybe they're getting
scans
I know but Dad
doesn't exist so it's kind of a doodle
man but that's what it is where where
else do they think that's just like for
the officer because also like people
walking by see the Machine they're not
gonna have like your new you're sorry
loads up on that I feel like my Fupa
would come through you know yeah because
if it's getting a silhouette they're
gonna have like my belly hang that like
hangs over my vagina oh we got a photo
of the woman going through that Oh big
shape really crazy really okay I'm hope
they caught it in time
early sending prayers and just get your
mammograms it's just a great reminder
this is what I say over 40 every year
right yeah yeah I've only seen a
mammogram getting done on TV because
they weirdly do it like on every Real
Housewives franchise it looks so painful
like these future boobs so hard but like
so important if you're over 40 are steel
coasters
go get your mammograms yeah just and
always be checking those breasts I am
always I'm just touching my breast in
the bathtub
great place to do it but like I feel
like I don't really know what alum feels
like and it's just like there's a lot of
skin and tissue and like fat in my boobs
so I'm like is that a lot yeah there's
some there's dense breast tissue like
some rays have actually a spoiler alert
I do and so I had to actually know Mike
so sometimes like what feels like lumps
is just like breast tissue so I actually
went to a specialist and I had to get a
sonogram on things just like make sure
cuz you don't know what you're feeling
and it was like a very thorough checkup
and I didn't know that me neither so
discreet I just like I get my [ __ ] done
right but I feel like I would know that
you got like a sonogram on your boobs
like I just feel like that would be like
a thing you write in the chat
maybe but like I think I would just
write if there was like some news to
[ __ ] I don't know yeah thank you
that's enough like I have to bring other
people into it no totally and I remember
as a kid I get my titties felt up in the
bed in the doctor's office I meet a man
doctor I'm like this is so weird now I'm
like dr. Freilich she touched my titties
sees me what male doctor touched your
boobs they have to squeeze you to check
the check for let's say your checkup
today not unless they do oh my gosh the
only doctor like back in the day like
when you have breast buds when the
breasts are about I think they do it
even like over your bra but it felt so
we are now I'm like I don't think they
do it thoroughly enough
go to dr. Freilich I'm like do it again
check again squeeze me harder like I
just it's it's not there enough for me
you know yeah the more the merrier well
that's just a good PSA for a Friday yeah
boobs checked um we've just been
watching jeffree star videos oh yeah all
week so I just want to say like I did it
first and then I got snitch and Jackie
into it and like since she hasn't really
taken to it like jackie has no I've been
meaning to watch the series I just like
haven't gotten around to it honestly I
just well so now I watch the old sheet
Nelson Jeffery story they talked about
the canceled yeah and when was that film
cuz if on the one hand it feels like it
was a long time ago but then on the
other hand it's like a year ago because
he had his he's doing blood sugar was
just recently issued this was only like
I feel like eight months ago
yeah and they had so much success from
the series that they wanted to do it on
and I think like literally the series
finish and so they started filming their
next one where they made the palette
that they talked about also shane
tweeted new episodes next Monday and
Tuesday and then the palette launches
I'm getting it it's neutrals it is yeah
did you see the most recent episode he
was saying it's like honest you don't
want that many crazy colors because yeah
I feel like because he was doing a like
a what's the [ __ ] word focus group
with his friend yeah just as like a
regular girl who wears regular makeup
that's Rylan sister oh it is yeah I've
been doing in Betsey I've been trying to
understand is Rylan also a youtuber I
know okay so I went really far down on
Jane's Instagram like to see Jesus just
his life and I found a picture where he
announces that he's dating Ryland and
he's introducing Ryland so I don't think
he was in exist to her okay so but I
think now that Ryan's like in this
YouTube world
he and his sister he like does videos
with his sister like if you go to
Megan's channel is that her name Moore
Morgan Morgan her and Rylan do videos
together Oh cute and she is like 2
million subscribers and it's like her
little family was so nice did you did
the palate you got calm yet oh you know
what I got an email that it was
delivered but I didn't check I was just
so busy like communicating with Jeffers
stars team yesterday that like I just
couldn't because you know I was being
major thirst monster I was watching some
old Jeffery star videos like I've seen
all the new ones and it's like he hasn't
been releasing
while the Shan series is so it's like
really annoying like I usually get a
video week so I'm going back and
watching like super old videos that I've
never seen like into the sponsored video
and he really liked his assistant Maddy
does everything with him but he's like
he's so respectful like he just treats
her like a friend like she he's like
come see it like he's just like such an
and I was like I'm so interested in this
Maddy figure so I followed I went to
Jeffrey's following an Instagram I found
her turn touch files lunge and quads and
I was like oh [ __ ] yes followed her back
and then she Deanna me she was like oh
my god Jeffery was sending a package and
I was like shut the [ __ ] up
I don't know if he like actually even
like she like even spoke to him but like
I'm gonna pretend like she did or maybe
she's just like taking the initiative
you know like as a executive assistant
but whatever like I'm cool with that
and I'm I'll be expect so I'm like
really waiting for that package now
she's had the next few days so I'm not
really like dying like to get this
package me and Margaret were two jeffree
star cosmetics like a lipstick but like
I'm now I'm waiting for like my
personalized items from Jeffery I'm
seeing conflicting accounts on Ryland
was youtuber before Browns youtuber now
he became into where I don't know he
like did clever news I don't know wait I
think we have some breaking news we have
some breaking news Felicity Huffman has
been released from prison
NBC News lesson week yeah week I think
it might be a week it's gonna be well
she had two weeks and then while we were
in LA while we were on lady gangs that
was on it was Wednesday every that was a
Tuesday so are we gonna have a weekend
to date oh no it's Friday she was there
for 11 days Wow Felicity Huffman
released from prison before and a 14 day
sentence this is from NBC News she was
released on Friday after serving under
two weeks for her role she began her
14-day sentence on October 15th but was
released early as his normal policy for
inmates we're set to be released on
weekends oh that's so interesting if
you're smart to be released on a weekend
they let you out early out to get the
whole weekend long weekend yeah that's
nice Wow I can't leave it's over she
must be so relieved like Lori Loughlin
journey hasn't even started yet
and Felicity Huffman is done yeah I'm
sorry let's see I mean that's how you do
it you take a look a champ right right
but Felicity 1/2 mins crime was a lot
less than Laurie Lachlan so like 14 days
know just the scale of it but they both
committed the same crime right right
right but it's like Felicity Hoffman
Huffman I mean they're Jewish
Felicity Huffman like robbed a
concession stand and like loyal often
robbed a bank
never share Billy crime dippin scale
but the punishments are different right
is what I'm saying is that like a
teachers have been done because Laurie
was never getting 14 days yes she'll
also have to pay $30,000 and perform 250
hours of community service under the
sentence handed down by the US District
Judge Indira Tawana last month Wow
Gracie times he's done she must like
she's gonna go home to make the biggest
Judy ever want to leave I heard that
prison is [ __ ] glamorous and chic and
they've liked sunbathing rooftop I'm
sure she meditation I'm sure she want to
go home
I don't know believe me choice it seems
like it's kind of tough to Mary tale
like she was taking some time off yeah
just really feeling rejuvenated her skin
is clear they get back to her yeah ready
they go back to work first shirt oh I
want to get a long interview Oh she'd uh
I don't know she's gonna do she doesn't
need it like she's not thirsty like
every time something happens with Teresa
like and Joe like there's still paying
restitution like they need all the press
the money the interviews that they can
get just to further get them out of this
hole so it's no surprise that they do an
interview with Andy every time something
happens but Felicity Huffman she don't
need the money she don't need the press
I'm sure she just wants silence yeah
yeah and just wants to move on and like
go act somewhere just throw herself into
her work you know yeah I just love doing
that yeah no I'm definitely the type of
person who like when times get tough I
really throw myself into my work yeah
and it shows like in the work you can
see all the raw emotion thank you you're
welcome
so beautifully sad honestly the only
thing I can talk about these days no
idea I'll get some back to Jeffrey star
um so yes I we heard from his team and
she was like definitely talking about
maybe getting him on the toast like we
will literally fly out there and like
filming performance house I know be
super private like we like I will do
literally anything like do and but you
know I'm just I'm I don't even want to
get my hopes up so I'm gonna pretend
like that's never gonna happen at all so
he lives in the same gated community in
Calabasas is all the Kardashians like
once we get everything we're never
leaving I'm getting its bring a tent and
like tons of water bottle so I could
survive for like a month
yeah so the old series was like so what
different different and just like
educational in terms of like how Jeffrey
got started but and Shane kept saying
this that like I feel as though we still
haven't gotten to how you got like how
that became this yep there's a gap and I
still feel that way but I just like I
love him and I feel like he's such a
great friend and
but his reputation is that he's a shitty
friend but he was like so ride-or-die no
totally like he like Shane has been so
good to him and like really changed his
life I think with the first series that
and like Geoffrey is so appreciative so
grateful like can't stop buying things
for Shane like just wants him to know
that he's appreciated and it shocks me
that like a person like who a person is
and who a person who people think a
person is like can be so different you
know yeah and I really feel like in this
case like they're complete opposites
yeah no I totally agree he's just like
such a softy and like a sweetheart and
genuine and also like does what needs to
be done you know and he takes care of
everyone around him because like now
we're learning more so like nate is
obviously his like partner mm-hmm they
live together Zach
the guy who films for Geoffrey his
Nate's brother oh and they all live in
the house together interesting yeah and
then he is another guy who works man
who's like not related but it's like I
guess he took Nate out of Grand Rapids
Michigan and Nate is super close with
his brother who's like a brother can
come with us too and then he bought a
house in Michigan right and Nate's
family lives there and it's just like so
they go back and forth to Michigan a lot
and I didn't realize that their house in
Michigan that they just like bought and
built is also the home for Nate's family
- who's Nate grew up like on the wrong
side of the tracks love it it's just
like the whole backstory is interesting
I need an actual e true Hollywood story
like an in-depth one really like a
two-hour special yeah there's a lot that
we missed I also ordered a bunch of
stuff what'd you get I got a couple
lipsticks I got a concealer in my shade
I really wanted was sold out so I got
something like a little lighter
hopefully it works and I got a green
color correcting concealer oh um and I
think I got three lipstick I don't know
I spent a hundred bucks so oh and I got
one of his handheld mirrors oh you did
I need shoulder merch I want some of his
track suits yeah I would see the merch
um it's really cute but nothing that I
got yet but as my stand who continues I
get a little mouth yeah I'm just like
I'm living for like I put it on my TV
usually watch YouTube on my phone but
yesterday I got so desperate like for
content that I actually put it on my TV
I can only watch YouTube videos on my TV
like it's my home you know
I know like some Mitchell sent me a
video and like I won't catch it for a
few weeks until I'm sitting down
watching like YouTube channel you won't
even watch a music video for three
minutes on your phone it's so
unbelievably
not like explore your explore paid too
much videos on Instagram no although
that's all that's all I do anyway I used
to watch BuzzFeed tasty videos like
remember like when we were in college
like those videos were had swept the
nation like there wasn't a kid on the
subway who wasn't watching one of those
stupid videos yes that's now what I do
with like beauty videos and like music
videos on Instagram and YouTube I can't
do it that's crazy
we gotta balance because we have an
interview with a major celebrity so we
got to go thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning trusted
millennial Morning Show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching on
YouTube please make sure to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up and leave a
comment we're also available as a
podcast but you obviously know if you're
listening to us as a podcast and mine
1111 wish right now is that you'd
subscribe to us ism as on a podcast on
Spotify iTunes stitcher public radio
cast box I Heart Radio on that you go
get some merch at morning toast calm
because we have that premium things it's
getting cold out there and you need a
big cozy sponge in a hoodie you also
need to let people know that you are
like into premium content therefore you
watch the morning toast and head on over
there get your stuff I just my merch
just got delivered in the mail I ordered
something too I ordered something only
Tuesday or Wednesday and I'm so excited
I don't even know what I got excited
everybody had anything everything we
love you guys thank you so much we hope
you have an amazing Friday extreme
Kanye's album when it comes out to
support you know partners and friends
the toast we love you guys have an
amazing day yeah happy weekend don't
drink and drive
[Music]
you